vous avez interrompu une enquête
prioritaire voler une pièce à conviction
d'une scène de crime active effectuer la
seule personne qui avait des enfants
si vous lui était ce type n'a pas été le
cas jessica jones ne dit plus rien vous
êtes cuivre m'appelle matthew murdoch
je suis votre avocat
[Musique]
man le héros de harlem peut-il espérer
vivre une vie normale mais aujourd'hui
je veux juste aider les gens je crois
qu'il faut que tu rencontres quelqu'un
et que tout bloquer t'es qui toi toi
t'es qui
comment ça se fait qu'ils sentent rien
c'est quoi le truc avec ton point je
suis le iron fist immortel t'es quoi
vous êtes dans le même camp vous êtes 4
le démon des sketches ou la détective
futé ya un problème
l'ex taulard accord qui je suis désolé
et le gamin au poing d'acier
new york est en guerre
et ça
il faut vous initier vos forces
vous aurez de connexion avec eux
plus il sera facile de vaud brisé vous
avez vraiment leur camp
[Musique]
c'est votre foulard qui fait ça
une sacrée équipe
non qu'est ce que tu racontes toi tu es
à l'épreuve des balles
toi tu es ninja aveugle donc toucher pas
trop ce côté la classe incarnée